Три чверті депутатів уперше пройшли до Верховної Ради
і стали новачками в політиці. Кожна п'ята - жінка.
Про ефективність роботи нових політиків та про гендер
будемо говорити з Юлією Клименко -
донедавна очільницею політичної партії "Голос",
а нині відповідальною за економічні питання.
- Пані Юліє, доброго дня!
- Добрий день!
Ви представляєте  нечисленну політичну силу:
20 голосів у вас лише буде.
Яке місце ви бачите для себе в парламенті?
Нас буде 20. Всі з нашого списку - це молоді професіонали,
які готові працювати в своїх галузях, у комітетах.
Я думаю, що ми можемо принести достатньо експертизи до Верховної Ради для того,
щоб зробити найкращий порядок денний для України.
У коаліцію будете йти? Були якісь перемовини?
Перемовини ми не коментуємо,
тому що інформації зараз немає і немає чого Вам сказати.
Тобто з вами не зв'язувалися чи ви з ними?
Ми не можемо зв'язуватися, бо повинна, мабуть, зв'язуватися
та партія, яка має більшість і яка буде формувати
і політику, і коаліцію, і розподіляти комітети,
але поки що це не на часі, поки затишшя.
Чи не думаєте, що вам як нечисленній партії треба самим звертатися до партії,
яка створює більшість і таким чином показати свою зацікавленість у тому,
щоб створити коаліцію і впливати на формування уряду?
У політичних процесах це зазвичай не працює,
тому що той, хто набирає більшість, несе більшу відповідальність.
Влада йде разом із відповідальністю.
Якщо ти маєш більше влади, ти маєш більше відповідальності і ти зацікавлений у тому,
щоб працювати з партнерами, або ділити цю відповідальність, або щось пропонувати.
Я думаю, це більш правильний політичний процес, ніж, скажімо так, зворотній.
Після оголошення результатів виборів Ви казали, що пропонуєте
кандидатуру Святослава Вакарчука на посаду прем'єр-міністра. Що змінилося сьогодні?
Я думаю, що в першу чергу змінилися результати виборів. Ніхто не очікував,
що "Слуга народу" стільки кандидатів зможе набрати на мажоритарних округах,
тобтовони вибороли більшість мажоритарних округів.
Всі казали, що буде 40-60 мажоритарних округів, які виграє "Слуга народу".
У результаті вийшло більше 120-130.
І це  абсолютно змінює ситуацію.
Як ви правильно сказали, це монобільшість, і вона повинна
брати на себе відповідальність і фактично формувати і уряд,
і призначати прем'єр-міністра.
І це правильно, логічно - я б так сказала.
На жодну кандидатуру в уряді Ваша політична сила не може розраховувати?
Це буде зрозуміло після того, як будуть розпочаті перемовини.
На даний момент інформації немає, тому немає про що особливо говорити.
Так, у "Слуги народу" є 254 депутати і цього достатньо для того,
щоб проводити більшість законопроектів і робити зміни,
в тому числі в регламенті Верховної Ради.
Цього не достатньо для зміни Конституції, але будемо дивитися, як буде розвиватись.
Коли говоримо про зміну Конституції, йдеться передусім про
законопроект, який усі українці чекають:
скасування недоторканності депутатів.
- Абсолютно.
Які ще законопроекти?
Ми пропонували в тому числі обмежити вплив депутатів...
точніше, не вплив депутатів, а навести лад у роботі Верховної Ради.
Тому що ми знаємо, що депутати потрапляють у Верховну Раду і починають
прогулювати, перестають ходити на роботу, вирішують свої питання.
Тому наша ідея була не тільки зняити недоторканність,
а й не виплачувати зарплату депутатам, якщо вони прогулюють більше ніж 25% свого робочого часу
без будь-якої причини і також депутат має скласти мандат, якщо він
не приходить на роботу більше, ніж 50% часу. Це наші пропозиції.
Ми будемо наполягати на них і далі.
- Це імперативний мандат?
- Це щось таке.
Це справедливо з точки зору людей. Якщо ти не ходиш на роботу в офіс,
тобі ж не платять заробітну плату.
Або не приходиш більше ніж 50% часу на роботу, тебе ж не чекає роботодавець.
Депутати - це фактично робітники, яких наймає український народ,
і вони повинні мати теж певні обмеження.
Пані Юліє, вже були озвучені чутки в медіа, хто може очолити МОЗ і МОН.
Ви вже бачите ті ініціативи Зеленського і його партії, які ви підтримаєте або не підтримаєте?
Я думаю, що це реально буде видно в парламенті, а також при формуванні Кабміну.
Це все залишається на рівні чуток. І не хочеться це коментувати,
тому що ситуація може бути в серпні абсолютно іншою.
Зарано говорити про те, що уже вирішено, хто буде в МОН, хто буде в МОЗ.
Але поки ми говоримо про "зарано", там уже, очевидно, ухвалюються рішення
і формуються якісь кандидати.
Чесно кажучи, я не думаю так. Я думаю, це все буде формуватися після першого засідання парламенту.
Можливо, вже на перше засідання парламенту, яке, я так розумію,  буде на День незалежності,
можливо, і буде запропонований Кабінет міністрів. Але поки зарано говорити.
Так само, як об'єднання Міністерства спорту, культури і інформаційної політики...
Мені здається, інформаційна політика - це наскрізна політика для всіх міністерств,
по всьому Кабінету міністрів, так само по всій адміністрації президента, а також у парламенті.
Тому що просто зробити частину департаменту якогось гуманітарного міністерства...
це не дасть абсолютно ніякого ефекту. Чесно Вам скажу,
ідея Міністерства інформаційної політики трохи дивна.
Воно повинно бути в кожному міністерстві.
Те, що називається англійською мовою "one voice policy":
коли в Кабінеті міністрів є один комунікаційний відділ назовні
і також комунікаційний відділ, який доносить інформацію до українських та іноземних глядачів.
Тоді воно зрозуміло.
Я не вірю, що один департамент у міністерстві у стані зробити
інформаційну політику на всю державу.
До речі, якщо говорити про комунікацію, молодим партія, зокрема і вам,
закидають те, що недопрацювали на Сході України…
Ми просто не встигли. Ми їхали на Схід,
наша агітаційна кампанія була теж на Сході.
Ми проїхали дуже багато міст, містечок і областей. Це і Харківська область,
і Дніпропетровська, і Донецька, і Луганська. Ми, в принципі, покрили весь Схід:
і Одеса, і південь, і Херсон, і Миколаїв. Але питання в тому, що
за 30 днів кампанії донести свої ідеї до такої великої країни практично неможливо.
На Схід і на Південь треба більше зусиль і часу. Це не означає, що ми там
зупиняємося, просто треба над цим працювати.
Просто, якщо ви знаєте, багато років ні Сходу, ні Півдню
фактично правлячі еліти не приділяли уваги,
це були такі феодальні утворення
і туди зазвичай центральна влада ніколи не доходила,
і це неправильно.
І громадяни постійно обирають своїх кандидатів,
тобто є чітко визначена партія, цього разу це "Опозиційна платформа"...
Бо вони не бачать альтернативи.
Для того, щоб вони вибирали, їм треба дати вибір.
Якщо на даний момент у них домінує Опоблок,
тому що він територіально і вже багато років там знаходиться,
і ніхто так і не зміг проникнути ні на Схід, ні на Південь,
в тому числі і після Революції Гідності, то це не проблема цих мешканців.
Це проблема політичних еліт, які не можуть все-таки донести свої ідеї і показати,
що буває по-іншому. Альтернативи немає.
Ви плануєте розвивати там партію, не лише на заході?
Так, ми не бачимо себе як регіональна партія, ми - національна партія
і ми будемо розвиватися як національна партія.
На початку інтерв'ю я казала про те, що кожна п'ята у Верховній Раді - жінка.
Як ви ставитеся до таких змін у Верховній Раді
і наскільки це може вплинути на ефективність роботи?
У першу чергу я жінка, і я дуже рада, що у нас така кількість жінок,
і ми вже зустрічалися міжфракційним об’єднанням - жінки між собою.
Я думаю, що робота з жінками завжди більш…
я не хочу нічого казати... але
жінки конструктивніші і вони більш націлені на те, щоб знайти рішення.
Не просто зайти в якийсь глухий політичний процес, а саме знайти рішення.
Тому я думаю, що жінки знайдуть спільну мову незалежно від політичної приналежності.
Ваша політична сила, так само як і "Європейська солідарність", набрала достатню кількість жінок,
аби отримати фінансування за жіночою квотою від держави.
Це сталося випадково чи справді намагалися підібрати?..
Ні, ми не намагалися підібрати жінок тільки для того, щоб отримати
додаткове державне фінансування або витримати гендерну квоту.
Насправді це вийшло досить органічно.
У нашому списку ви побачите досить багато самостійних і цікавих жінок,
яким цікаво працювати на державу, в парламенті і доносити свої ідеї.
Це просто тенденція сучасного світу, де жінки
все ж таки мають рівні можливості з чоловіками і хочуть приймати активну участь
не тільки в якомусь рутинному житті, бізнесі і сім'ї,
але хочуть реалізувати себе і в політиці, в громадянському суспільстві.
І мені здається, що це дуже добре.
Ті чоловіки, які думають по-іншому, ми би хотіли донести їм свою ідею як жінки,
що ми маємо рівні можливості і ми б хотіли мати ці рівні можливості далі.
Наскільки цей парламент може бути прогресивним, аби приймати такі
непопулярні речі для України, як, можливо, навіть, дозвіл для одностатевих шлюбів?
Цей парламент має шанс бути дуже ефективним,
бо в  нас є монобільшість.
Якщо порядок денний правлячої партії "Слуга народу"
буде дійсно відповідати європейському порядку денному
і буде для України прогресивним,
то вони дійсно мають шанс приймати його швидко,
бо їм не потрібно збирати голоси в трьох партіях, чотирьох,
переконувати... Це все одно займає певний процес.
Але якщо вони будуть мати деструктивний порядок денний,
безумовно, це може повернутися в будь-яку іншу сторону.
Але навіть якщо ти маєш більшість, це не означає, що ти можеш
приймати рішення без того, щоб обговорити його з партнерами по парламенту.
Тобто публічний діалог ніхто не відміняв
і завжди треба переконувати навіть партії,
які набрали менше голосів, у тому, щоб вони голосували,
щоби це мало певну легітимність,
щоб люди розуміли, куди вони йдуть.
Бо так чи інакше це буде створювати певні конфлікти
і воно не буде йти в конструктивне русло.
Які важелі впливу можуть бути в парламенті, якщо рішення будуть
неправильні, будуть не подобатися громадянам,
але партія все одно буде їх приймати?
У парламенті будуть ці важелі впливу, коли вони можуть не дозволити проголосувати?
Є юридична, а є публічна сторона. Питання в тому, що в нашій країні
публічна сторона і громадянське суспільство
працює набагато ефективніше, ніж будь-які державні органи.
Тому якщо ми будемо не згодні з чимось
і будемо вважати, що це шкодить інтересам України,
то ми будемо, безумовно, це доносити до людей,
це буде публічна риторика з нашої сторони.
Якщо ми маємо 20 депутатів, цього достатньо,
щоб донести громадськості, що це рішення шкодить інтересам України.
Хотілося б уточнити і дізнатися більше щодо державної підтримки політичних сил.
Наскільки вона необхідна, наскільки допомогла вашій політичній силі
і чи треба знижувати бар'єр до 3%?
Я думаю, що 5% - це абсолютно конкурентний бар'єр.
Можуть потрапити не одна партія і не дві, а в цей парламент потрапило п’ять партій.
Я думаю, що державне фінансування обов'язково повинно бути,
щоб всі партії починали думати саме про партійну розбудову,
щоб були можливості це реалізовувати і не дивитись на те,
чи є гроші, чи дав сьогодні олігарх гроші, чи не дав.
Чи вони змогли фандрейзинг, чи не змогли.
Тобто якщо подолали 5% бар'єр, державне фінансування повинно забезпечуватися
і партія повинна розростатися і доносити свої ідеї до широких мас.
Для нас це велика справа,
бо на виборчу кампанію ми зібрали у малому і середньому бізнесі,
але їх навряд чи вистачить, щоб розбудувати повноцінну партію.
Тому державне фінансування буде значною інвестицією в нашу розбудову.
Через п'ять років як ви бачите партію?
Через 4 роки і 2 місяці в парламенті, я сподіваюсь,
це буде велика національна партія, яка розростається
і яка зможе донести свій порядок денний
за ці роки не тільки на Захід і Центр, а, як Ви правильно сказали, теж на Схід і на Південь.
І ми будемо мати більше можливостей,
аби донести свої ідеї до людей.
Можливо партія "Самопоміч" теж так думала, але щось пішло не так...
Хтось приходить, хтось іде. Але якщо у виборця є великий вибір,
це краще, ніж не мати цей вибір.
Це були, мабуть, перші парламентські вибори, коли люди голосували "за", а не "проти",
бо ми завжди приходили на виборчі дільниці  голосувати проти когось:
і на парламентські, і на президентські.
Це були вибори, коли ви мали альтернативу,
ви могли проголосувати "за" і вони були більш позитивні й конструктивні,
ніж за попередні 28 років. Це моє відчуття як виборця.
Дякую Вам за інтерв'ю!
Будь ласка.